right this sunday marks 115 years since
the day bugsy siegel was born he was an
american mobster
who was the driving force behind the
development of the las vegas strip
so it only makes sense that our city
remember this front page celebrity
gangster with a specialty cocktail
i have jonathan and joe from bugsy and
myers inside the flamingo hotel and they
have a special
bugsy birthday cocktail guys show us how
you do it
hello lindsay and all the viewers out
there my name is johnny pacheco the
general manager here at
bugsy and myers takeouts located in las
vegas
flamingo las vegas nevada standing with
me is our mixologist
joe well he will be here uh helping us
create our
bugsy spritz in order to celebrate
bugsy seagulls uh actually he would be
turning 115
this week celebration we created a
special drink in this uh
in his honor which again was called the
bugsy uh spritz
it's our classic take of a 1950
classic spritz we take a couple of
wonderful products
uh fresh ingredients like our garber
mouth our fresh
pink uh grapefruit the core with fresh
lime
fresh raspberries and top it off with a
little sparkling wine and moscato
with fresh raspberries and legally
obtained 24
karat gold flakes with the steel
of for 20 dollars with that being said
again
buzzy was a huge uh innovator for las
vegas
not only that himself and his business
partner meyer lance he created uh
uh the fabulous flamingo las vegas back
in 1946
uh bugsy also was the leading fourth
behind the development of the
las vegas strip uh he also was the uh
innovator in the first resort style
hotel so which ever changed the
landscape
of vegas the restaurant itself has a
great
resort feel to it that pays homage to
the past
with a little nuts uh and then with just
a bit
of new twists and added added freshness
to elevate uh the look and feel of our
resorts
as soon as you walk into uh bugsy meyer
steakhouse you'll be transported by
walking through into our facade bakery
through the kitchen and then through you
through the unique
six six unique uh venues that they're
the offer that the venue offers
so again please join us between february
the 28th sunday through march the 7th
to get our wonderful bubsy spritz
cocktail for a steal of twenty dollars
look forward to seeing you guys
thank you thank you so much it looks so
good i'm thirsty
all right guys las vegas now we'll be
right back